in the last video we were able to show
that any lambda that satisfies this
equation for some nonzero vectors V then
the determinant of lambda times I the
identity matrix minus a must be equal to
0 or we could rewrite this as saying
lambda is an eigen value eigen value of
a if and only if all right it is if if
and only if the determinant of lambda
times the identity matrix minus a is
equal to 0 now let's see if we can
actually use this in any kind of
concrete way to figure out I gain values
so let's do a simple 2x2 let's deal in
r2 let's say that a is equal to the
matrix one two and four three and I want
to find the eigen values of a so if
lambda is an eigen value of a let's say
lambda is eigen value of a then this
right here tells us that the determinant
of lambda times the identity matrix so
it's going to be the identity matrix in
r2 so lambda times 1 0 0 1 minus a 1 2 4
3 is going to be equal to 0 well what is
this equal to this right here is the
determinant of lambda times this is just
lambda times all of these terms so it's
lambda times 1 is lambda lambda times 0
is 0
lambda times 0 0 lambda times 1 is
lambda and from that we'll subtract a so
you get 1 2 4 3 and this has got to
equal 0 and then this matrix or this
difference of matrices this is just so
keep the determinant this is the
determinant of this first term is going
to be lambda minus 1 lambda minus 1 the
second term is 0 minus 2 so it's just
minus 2 the third term is 0 minus 4
so it's just minus four and then the
third the fourth term is lambda minus 3
lambda minus 3 just like that so kind of
a shortcut to see what happened the
terms along the diagonal
well everything became a negative right
we negated everything under the terms
around the diagonal we've had a lambda
out front that was essentially the
byproduct of this expression right there
so what's the determinant of this 2 by 2
matrix
well the determinant of this is just
this times that minus this times that
so it's lambda minus 1 times lambda
minus 3 minus minus these two guys
multiplied by each other so minus 2
times minus 4 is plus 8 minus 8 this is
the determinant of this matrix right
here of this matrix right here or this
matrix right here which simplify to that
matrix and this has got to be equal that
has got to be equal to 0 and the whole
reason why that's got to be equal to 0
is because we saw earlier this matrix
has a non-trivial null space because it
has a non-trivial null space it can't be
invertible and it's determinant has to
be equal to 0 so now we have an
interesting polynomial equation right
here we can multiply it out we get what
let's multiply it out we get lambda
squared right minus 3 lambda minus 3
lambda minus lambda plus 3 minus 8 is
equal to 0 or lambda squared lambda
squared minus 4 lambda minus 4 lambda
minus 5 minus 5 is equal to 0 and this
in case you're want to know some
terminology this this expression right
here is known as the characteristic
polynomial the characteristic polynomial
just a little terminology polynomial but
if we want to find the eigenvalues for a
we just have to solve this right here
this is just a
basic quadratic problem and this is
actually factorable to see two numbers
and you take the product as minus five
when you add them you get minus four by
it's minus 5 and plus one so you get
lambda minus five times lambda plus one
is equal to zero right minus 5 times 1
is minus 5 and then minus 5 lambda plus
1 lambda is equal to minus 4 lambda so
the two solutions of our characteristic
equation being set to 0 our
characteristic polynomial our lambda is
equal to 5 or lambda is equal to minus 1
so just like that using the information
that we prove to ourselves in the last
video we're able to figure out that the
two eigenvalues of a are lambda equals 5
and lambda equals negative 1 now that
only just solves part of the problem
right we know we're looking for AI ghen
values and eigenvectors right we know
that this equation can be satisfied with
lambdas equaling 5 or minus 1 so we know
the eigenvalues but we're yet to
determine the actual eigenvectors so
that's what we're going to do in the
next video